没。
上课了啊，同学们。
这个今天天气非常的炎热啊，非常热。现在上课已经越来越痛苦了，每次上课都像洗了一澡，浑身衣服都湿透了，只是你们看不出来而已。
咱开始录这个课的时候还很冷，我记得。
他录了有。
4个月了。
妇女节那天录的第一课嘛，录了4个月了。
这个从寒冬路到盛夏。
对吧天气非常热啊，为什么这么热？同学们说，那你开个空调呗。
就是我这个课呀，我是在疫情隔离期间开始录的，所以这间房啊。
就是我加了一个很小的一个房间。
很小的一个房间支上几个这个这个灯，瓦数都挺大的，因为要录织上几盏以后，你空调也把温度也打不下来，非常热。这个房间很小，这其实也不是个黑板啊，这是面墙，我要洗的时候挺过瘾，每次擦的时候很痛苦，你知道吗？都是用这个湿抹布才能擦掉。
所以这也不是个黑板。
天气很热啊。
这个今天我还在开玩笑说呢，我说我们以前拍戏的时候啊，夏天的戏。
如果没有空调的情况下。
比如说那个外景没有空调的时候，或者是同栖生，同栖生棚内也不能开空调。
然后没有空调的时候。
特别热。
演员还带着妆，确实妆都挂不住啊。
有时候真的是。
没招的时候，我们怎么处理啊？我们那时候。
我们去订那个冰。
不是食用冰，我们去冷库那种叮那种大。
这么大一块。
回来之后啊自己砸开。
拿那个大桶大盆把那个冰放在里边，然后拍那种特别热的戏的时候，你知道怎么拍？
往地上一放，演员站进去。
脚一凉，浑身都都不热。
站进去之后真的挺爽。
我们在旁边监视器那儿，我们不能把脚放进去，我们弄一个。
然后所有导演组的人一人伸一只胳膊进去。
就很凉快已道。
所以我那还说呢，我说如果天持续这么热，咱这个课又要坚持录。
我也搞一个大盆，放点冰进去，我站在里面讲。
所以同学们哪天看到我讲课写写板书的时候这么写，脚不动，身体动，你就知道我热的受不了了，好吧，你们也不要奇怪。
哎呀，今天这节课那咱就就赶紧上课吧啊，天热也不废话。
讲点什么呢？
今天这节课的内容啊。
讲一讲。
项目提案。
为啥要讲项目提案啊？同学们啥叫项目提案？
就是说。
在很多情况下。
你这个剧本不是直接发给别人。
明白这个意思吧？你要么没写完。
或者你要么没有必要全发给他，或者你为了保护自己，不能把所有的创意都漏给人。
在这种情况下呢，大家一般是用什么东西交流呢？
就是用一个提案去交流。
就是我告诉你，我有个项目了，我有个剧本了，呈现给你看一看甲方爸爸要不要买单，对吧？
这个这个你要不要或者咱要不要合作？在很多情况下，你需要一个提案。
我为什么发现这个东西有必要讲一下呢？
就是很多同学交给我的这个东西呀，交给我的那个作业呀。
真的是看不下去。
特别的没有章法，没有格式混乱。你说你作为一个文字工作者。
你拿出手的东西。
你不能让人赏心悦目，不能让人愉快的阅读。
你怎么能让人相信你能写好一个剧本呢？同学们。
很多人教给我的东西。
有的跟我说，老师，我知道你很忙，我就不发全剧本给你了。
我发个简单的几百字梗概，你看看吧。
结果这几百个字全是前十。
全是讲这个男主角。
以前的故事。
根本没有竞争文。
要么就是给我几场戏。
123三场戏，三个场景。
我也没看明白你这三场戏的选的意义是什么。
什么也看不出来。
所以呢。
这节课咱们就花点时间把这个项目提案。
给大家讲一讲。
按理说呢这种知识啊。
我是不太爱讲。
为啥？
因为他严格来说算不上知识。
对吧。
它不属于写剧本的范围。
它属于包装你的剧本，包装你的项目，让别人更爱看，对吧？它有点像什么呢？像我是一个我是一个老师，我应该给你们讲知识讲题。但是呢我这节课给你们讲猜题和押题。
是吧。
比如说选择题三长一短，选短的，三短一长选长的。
这几个我就给你们讲这种东西了。
确实不太好。
但是呢讲讲一讲也有有也有也有用。因为这个这个玩意儿啊过了这个村没这个店儿，你别的地儿学不到。
除非你到一个。
好的影视公司去上班，你去会去接触到一些老前辈做的。
剧本的项目提案，我说的项目提案不是影视项目提案，是剧本的项目提案。影视的项目提案是下一步的，是要结合导演组、制片组和这个制作公司大家再再出，我们先出。
剧本的项目起案。
就是你有一个剧本，你如何能把它卖掉？
对吧如何让人别人觉得你这个剧本靠谱？
你这个人靠谱。
很多同学教过来的东西，我说。
哎呀，咱们是干这行的，对不对？你你拿过来一张word，我天哪，我一看这张word，我不看内容，我就觉得你这不靠谱。
你这个人不靠谱。
对不对？这格式。
你这这这这版式或者是你的内容选的这个逻辑。
都都都有问题。所以咱这里可要讲一讲啊，哎，我讲一个我的体会啊，同学们。
我认识的。
写的好的编剧。
我认识的有水平的编剧。
基本上提案都做的很好。
真的就不会说出现一个编剧，他剧本写的很棒，但是你让他介绍一下他的项目，你让他出给他的项目的提案，他写的很差，不会的。我跟你说。
不会的，他只要剧本写的好，他提案都做的漂亮，因为他有逻辑。
他知道重点是什么。
而且呢更重要的是提案是什么玩意儿？提案是给别人看的。
你一个剧本是整个故事，你现在要摘出其中的一部分内容做提案。
如何能做的好？
就是你抛开自己，你清空自己，你不是你啦，你不是作者。
你是一个不知道这个剧本的。
关注。
或者是一个假班，然后呢，他来看你这个提案。
如何能舒服？
如何能看了之后，觉得我要买。
这是什么能力？
这是共情呀。
你换位到他的位置去，替他想一想他要看什么。
对不对？所以我跟你说，好的编剧体验都做的挺漂亮的。我真见过那。
特别那些女编剧啊，要人家的提案做的真的是让人羡慕，真的漂亮，真的漂亮。而且很多时候你也不需要做成PPT。因为咱编剧啊咱玩word就可以了，你就word，然后转1个PDF出来，一个漂漂亮亮提案，纯文字都可以。
对吧。
所以今天我给大家讲一讲啊，咱们课上的同学都把这个都要学会，就是你一个东西。
交给甲方。
如何让人家看书？
我回忆一下啊，我之前科长话上曾经说过。
我说过一句话，我说同学们哪。
在写这个。
写交给甲方的东西的时候。
可以加一些花里胡哨的形容词儿。
不切实际的形容词。
不符合剧本规定的一些东西，一些描述可以写。
为什么呢？我说因为可能有很多甲方有阅读障碍，对吧？你写了让他看的开心点。
这句话说的武断了啊。
嗯，这里纠正一下纠正一下，我啥意思呢？
不是甲方蠢。
不是这个意思。
是因为金主爸爸们呢普遍工作比较忙。
他时间有限，对不对？每天是那个李万机。
是吧你呢就得做一份简单明了。
重点明确的东西给人看。
对吧他不是光伺候你，人家得看很多份案子。
所以是这么个意思。
咱这节课呢就来研究研究如何做好一个提案，如何给甲方呈现一个好的东西。
好吧。
那这个剧本儿。
我们说。
你。
不给别人看，或者是说他没有时间看。
你如何快速的？
让他知道你这个剧本的亮点是什么，卖点是什么，或者更直接点说你如何让他买。
给他的理由，让他把这个剧本买了。
把这个项目买了。
我认为一个好的提案。
分这么几个部分。
第一部分那肯定是标题，这个的不用说了，对吧？然后第二个部分叫一句话故事。
这个一定要学会总监，叫一句话故事。第三个块叫。
标签卡。
第四部分。
叫。
人物小传。
然后接下来是。
等待。
然后。
就写这么几部分的内容，不要写太多，不要写太乱，对吧？
懂行的同学啊懂行的同学现在已经明白我这几天要讲些什么了，我们就按照这些东西写多余的东西不要写，不要去给人家画表。
不要去给人制图，说，哎，你看看我的人物关系。
写那么多人物干什么，对不对？听我的就写这么多。
就解这么多。
来，我现在逐个给大家讲一下啊。
标题不用说了，你这戏叫什么，你这剧本叫什么对吧？一个名字当然了，后面可以跟上你这个戏的，它是个电影，还是个电视剧，是个电影，你打算搞多长？
多少多少分钟多长时间，电视剧的话多少集，对吧？这个标标题。
包括这个这个这个这个长度，你给人写一下，然后一句话故事这里就要开始有点技术了。
一句话故事是什么呢？
一般就是人物事件。
人物和事件。
就是用一句话。
把你这个戏的人物和事件说明白。
比如说。
我们是药神。
一句话梗概咋说？
一句话故事咋提炼？
就是一个。
人物嘛一个。
卖印度神油的。
要贩子。
是这了。
到印度去走私。
治疗白血病的天价药。
叫什么来着？格列位是是吧？格列位。
来到故事。
就是一个卖神油的小贩。
去卖治白血病的青洁药。
这就是一句话故事。
一个想要殉职的警察。
对吧一句话会是怎么概括？
就是一个。
单向懦弱的前解。
想要在。
想要在工作中殉职。
想要牺牲。
这么一个故事。
这就是一句话故事。
一句话故事。
干啥用的？
就是按住你的观众。
按住你这个提案的观众，因为大部分人啊真的看到几百字几千字那种密密麻麻的字的时候，他真的头打了。你必须先给他一句话。
给人拍活住了。
就这一句话必须让他抬头。
到这种程度。
一般来说，那这一句话如何让人抬头呢？那就是你的人物和你主要的这件事儿。这个一句话故事啊是概念上的一句话啊，实在两句话也行因为这。
就是。
就是从阅读的角度来讲，就那一丢丢对吧？一丢丢谎。
就是什么人干了一个什么事儿。
就说这这个是你要做的第一件事情。
一句话故事。
然后第二件事情，这个标签强了。
这个标签墙。
标签墙这个啥意思？我们在网上经常用到说一个视频，他你得给他下一个下些标签啊，它有些什么样的标签，这个这个。
这个东西啊可以快速。
直观的。
让别人了解你这个故事的。
特点。
各种特点综合性的一个东西，而且简练。
对吧。
标签墙。
比如说。
这个这个。
嗯。
比如说我们说。
咱们那个想要殉职的警察。
对吧。
那这个。
剧本的标签上都有些什么？
都有些什么。
就他有些什么样的关键词呢？
经营费。
一个吧。
然后。
父女情。
啊。
对吧他他是因为女儿吧。
然后呢，这个这个。
动作场面要有吧，所以这个动作也是个标签吧。
然后。
他。
想死死不掉。
最后不想死的时候，反而死了，黑色幽默也是它的一个标签吧，也是它的一个属性吧。
就是说把你这个这个。
故事里面所能涉及到的。
所能。
成为关键词的。
关键纪简的。
都做成标签墙。
小蝌蚪找妈妈动画吧。
那么历险吗？
对不对？然后小蝌蚪我们说那个小蝌蚪想跳到观赏鱼鱼池里，想跟小金鱼一起投为不导演歌舞吧，音乐。
对不对？还有这个这个他跟娃娃之间兄弟情啊。
对不对？
然后这个这个冒险呀，这些都是在里面的呀。
就是这个。
标签墙能够快速的把你。
这个剧本的所有的关键词全部给出来。
也要能别人能。
很直观的。
了解你这个东西好不好？
有些什么样的卖点量？
第三部分，人物小传，这个很多同学问过。
很多同学问过我，人物小篆该怎么写？
这里今天就那详细给大家说一下。
首先说一下这个人物小传。
人物小传是不光是在提案里面有用。
人物小传。
很多人在写剧本的时候也会先划了一下。
先简单的规划一下人物小传，所以人物小传一般有两个作用。第一呢是帮助你自己去规划你的人物，设计你的人物，相当于是你人物的草稿蓝图。
还有一个作用呢，就是给你的合作方看。
比如说给到演员，你得告诉演员来，今天邀请您演这个角色到我这个系里来，对吧？这个。
这个人物大概是样什么样的一个人？你这个人物小张必须漂亮。
必须漂亮呀，否则对吧？本来2000万的演员谈这种小账不咋地，2500万。
才肯来演对吧？你就因为人物小传不好看，损失500万，何苦呢，对不对？所以人物小传给演员看这很重要，你得吸引他呀，因为演员真的。
演员真的就是。
虽然演员片酬前几年非常高高的很离谱，但是我跟你说，我接触到的大部分的有追求的演员。
嗯你给他好剧本的时候，他真的是不太在乎。
这个确实是这样。所以你这个所以我们说你的提R也要不到了，人物小传要够吸引人，那是很有用的，那是很有用的。
所以说你看人物小传得给演员看，对吧？合作方呃，剧组其他同人也看呀，比如说那个。
服装化妆。
哎，浮化组看人物小传来设计这个人物的这个。
基本的形象。
呃，造型什么的。
他也是看神物小传，你不可能要求那个每个服装师，每个化妆师都精通剧本啊，对吧？看你这个几十万字的剧本来确定对这个演员的认知。
最好，你得让人看小段，你这这个人物小段就写的好。
所以说这个。
人物小传还算挺重要的。
那咱这节课也借这个机会把人物小传单独给大家说一下，好吧。
人物小传的写法。
我认为。
分。
五个部分吧。
外在。
内在。
态度。
或者叫状态。
你们叫状态吧。
然后行动。
变好。
这是人物小传的写法。
我们说外在有哪些？
那就你们最熟悉的那些，你们自己都会写的那些姓名呀。
外表呀。
然后那个那个就是肉眼可见的他那个样子呀，对吧？还有什么比较重要的啊，除了这个这个外表呀、姓名呀。
名字对吧？然后比较重要的，还有什么那个那个身份。
对吧这个咱们之前讲过身份就是在戏中的身份。
还有什么比较重要的啊，人际关系别漏了。
他是谁的谁？
对吧特别是你如果好几个主角的话，或者是他不是最主要的那个主角，他跟主角的人际关系是什么？这个也很重要。
然后啊还有一个经常容易漏掉的东西，这个血统不要漏掉。
什么叫血统啊？什么叫一个角色血统？
就比如说他什么家庭出身。
他是什么？
一样的环境里面的人。
他或者是他的教育背景是什么？对吧？这个对一个角色塑造是很重要的。
你说他是知识分子家庭出来的。
他是胡同呃长大的。
然后呢，他是草原上。
孩子这是不一样的呀，对吧？或者是你看他是名校海归的。
对不对？他这这是这就是血统，这就是血统。
这就是外在，你能写你能规划这些东西。然后内在。
其实就性格。
性格。
他的性格特点对吧？然后他的偏好。
他由于性格会造成什么样的偏好，对不对？然后。
内在还有什么东西？
直播。
他的价值观呀，或者是还有很多他他的信仰呀，他信仰什么？这很重要呀。他的价值观他的信仰是什么？有些人就信仰弱肉强食。
对吧以暴制暴。
胜者为王，这也就是一种信仰的。还有一些人就是信仰公平公正，对吧？是信仰这个这个善有善报。
都是信仰，这都是内在的东西，好吧。
所以说内在也要写一下他的性格，他的偏好的价值或者他的信仰。
然后呢，状态哎你看啊一个人除了他外在。
是什么呀？内在什么样？他还有个状态问。
他有个状态。
比如说他是一个。
这个这这个。
很乐观的人。
啊。
很消极的人。
这些跟性格呢没有关系了，对吧？
他性格虽然暴躁，但是他可以很很。
很消极的暴躁或者很积极的暴躁嘛，对不对？他有个态度，他有个情绪，你知道吗？
他其实有个态度，有个情绪。
有个情绪，有个情绪状态，然后在这个这个状态这一栏，我们还可以。
在塑造人物的时候，还可以加入什么样的这个这个考量呢？就比如经常会用到。
他的应急反应。
应执反。
啥叫应急反应？就是遇到事儿之后的第一反应啊。
有些人遇到事儿之后，第一反应就是躲。
那还不关我事儿。
哎这事儿跟我没关。
有些人遇到是应急反应就撒谎。
有些撒谎尿屁的，是不是？
没一句实话。
有些人的这个这个应急反应就是。
赖对吧？所么样的人都有。
当然也有勇于承担责任的，都有啊被应激反应。还有什么呢？在这个状态这点还可以设计什么？就是口头语。
很多角色有口头语，有口头禅。
对吧它跟应急反应是一样的，应急反应是行为上的常态。
口头语口头禅是语言中的常态。
金剧的那些角色，这都很正常啊？
所以说你看人物。
既有外在，又有内在，还有个状态。
这三个呢是一组。
外在内在状态，这三个是一处。
然后设计好这三个之后，还要再设计什么呢？
行动。
这些都是静态的东西啊，他还要有行动呀。你这个角色的这行动是什么？
首先他得有个行动目标啊。
他在这个戏中想干啥？
是必须在人物小传里面设计出来的，他想干啥想去。
这个这个这个报酬对吧？小课楼我想去找妈妈嗯他有个目标。
然后基于这个目标，他肯定要采取行动嘛。这行动上他他肯定是为了这个目标才取行动嘛。那他采取这个行动。
他有什么样的？
资源。
或者叫优势。
然后呢，有什么样的缺陷？
或者叫命门啊、主力这些其实就是什么呢？就是。
你在设计人物的时候，他是要有行动的，行动呢要有一个目标，有了这个行动目标采取行动之后呢，他要有成或者不成两方面的。
对抗的力量。
什么能帮助他成，什么能阻碍他成。
你在这里也要设计一下。
或者是说要写下来呈现给。
看这个人物小传的。
甲方也好，演员也好。
同事也好，让他们看，让他们知道。
然后再就是变好。
就变。
就湖光呀。
别用胡光嘛。
你这个主要的人物，我们说主要的人物还配有人物扫庄呀。
有人物小传的这些主要人物都是要有呃湖光的呀。
大部分啊大部分都是要有零湖光的。
就是有变化。
那这么去理解的话，那前四个可以理解为骑视状态。你们发现这个问题了？
就是说一个人物啊。
他。
在这个故事中是有变化的。那么前三或者说前四是他的起示状态。
这个呢是它变化后的状。
他从最初一个什么样的人，最后变成一个什么样的人。
这么去理解这个问题，好吧。
那这就是人物小传的写法。
我们就还以我不是药神里面。
这个徐峥这个角色举例一下，看一下这个人物小小传，这个人物小传怎么去去构建，好吧。
来外代这个人物叫什么？叫陈勇是吧？我们就说陈勇这个角色啊。
曾用。
他在外面。
一个。
乐里勒特的。
中年男性对吧？
40岁左右。
其貌不扬，对吧？那发型整的确实也不咋地。
这是外形。首先要描述一下。
然后水粉。
他啥身份？
我们说身份是在这个故事中有用的那些身份，首先是个要贩子。
卖卖卖卖卖保健品吗？
然后呢。
是个父亲。
这个前夫。
是吧。
是个儿子。
他爹。
那个那个病重导致他铤而走险的嘛。
这些身份。
当然了，在这里你要写一个是一个。
呃。
什么样的潜夫呢？
曾经家暴的钱。
什么样的父亲呢？
有心无力的父亲，嘴上的好父亲，什么样的儿子呢？
孝顺了儿子。
叫什么。
就说这样的身份，然后同时也是他的人际关系。
对吧他有这项这些人际关系。
然后我们说内在来。
从那一代开始研究一下这个角色。
他的性格。
我们说他的第一个性格其实就是怂了。
就是软弱怂懦弱。
怎么判断一个角色？
怂了。
打女人的男人是最疯的呀，对吧？他在这个戏中上来第一个设定就是。
因为驾暴。
离婚了嘛，然后。
还有一些什么样的性格呢？
自私也算一个吧。
对吧光顾自己。
然后跟他儿子在一块的时候，又表现出死要面子。
明明没钱对吧？还是他儿子想买球鞋。
哎，你怎么不让你后爸买？听到儿子孩子站在这自己这边，然后就打肿脸冲胖了，给个几百块钱。
只是要面。
然后呢。
还有什么性格？
与咱们故事很有很有关系，很重要的。还有一个。
没有责任心。
不负责任。
首先他卖的那个药都不好使，他呦对吧？说人家老头说人家那个老头不行，对吧？说他那个老头不行。
说人家不好，然后呢，自己这个家庭。
他儿子的事儿那前妻的事儿，包括他爹的在养老院的费用。
他这个责任心都。
不强不负责任。
然后它的状态呢，它这个外在内在我们。
勾勒出来之后，那它的状态。
外在上这个这个这个一个呃失败的。
中年男性。
呃，卖保健品的。
然后血统呢是。
上海。
底层。
小老百姓。
对吧。
这个这个这个是一个不太称职的。
父亲和儿子。
是一个糟糕的前夫。
是这样一个外在，内在呢。
挺怂的。
然后呢，不太负责任，嗯，挺自私的。
呃，还死要面子。
对吧。
应该是没有什么信仰吧。
然后呢。
那这样一个人，他的生活状态是什么？
那他这样一个人他怎么活呢？他在社会上的状态是什么？这就是区别状态和内在的啊，大家要区分这个状态和内在有什么区别？那他的状态是什么？
我说他第一个状态就是赖。
赖呀是吧？赖那个。
那边。
不好，然后赖房租。
赖住院费，什么都赖拖是吧？这就是他的状态，赖拖躲对吧？就是他的生活状态。然后这个。
还有一些什么样的状态，吊儿郎啷的对吧？欺软怕硬，都是他的生活状态。
都是他的这个这个应激反应啊，欺软怕硬啊，对吧？
7万八现就很明确的，他小舅子来了，他不就怂了吗？人家是警察。
这就是程勇这个角色的外在内在状态，基本上就把人物勾勒出来。
然后呢，就要写一下他的行动。在这个戏里面行动是非常明确的，就是发现了可以到印度去。
走私。
格列位。
可以挣大钱。
啊。
通过。
他在印度的。
路子他本来就有走私情。
要的路子嘛。
然后呢去做这件事情。
但是这件事情是危险的，到后期开始有危险。
有很多第一人。
然后呢，他又。
不胆小。
贪财，但是胆小。
这就是他的资源和缺陷。
然后。
最后再写什么呢？这个角色的变化。
他的成长，他的湖光。
那我们就说。
前四个是起始状态。
最后一个是最终的状态，那我们就从起始状态里面找他哪些变化了。
他前面有自私吧，他从自私的自私的一个人变成了一个最后。
我们说自私的另外一念，那是奉献。
他不光奉献他自我牺牲的，对不对？从一个自私的人变成自我牺牲的人。
他前面懦弱。
懦弱吧要从一个懦弱胆小的人变成了一个英勇无畏的人。
这就是他的变化。
他从一个贪财的人。
变成了一个无私奉献的。
就是把这些变化再写出。
那综上所述，这5.1描述你这个成勇这个角色任物小张就出来。
而且很漂亮。
但是一定要注意一点。
你不要把这5个东西给写出来。
这五个东西你是要擦掉的。好吧，这是咱们的草稿，你光要写后面。
就5个东西把它擦掉，但是你要记在心里，先写外在方面的，再写内在方面的，再写状态层面的，再写行动。
最后。
线下它的变化。
你这样的话，你这个人物一下就立体了。看你这个人物小传的人。
很舒服。
他会觉得你很有逻辑，而且很全面。
但是你不能告诉他，我们是按照这5个。
解开写的。
不能告诉他，好吧。
那这就是人物小传。
这就是人物小传。
接下来写等待。
梗盖我之前讲过的。
梗概写什么？
梗概就是写八要素呀。
梗概住写发要素养。
我们说。
花要素是。
人物事件主题人物分成3个。
身份欲望动作。
对吧然后事件呢。
事界分什么问题阻力结果。
主题正价值、负价值。
那你这个梗盖就先把这。
啊还要熟悉。
一个什么样的人？
产生了一个什么样的想法？
有个什么样的。
欲望。
采取了什么样的行动？在这个行动的过程中。
最大的问题是什么？他能不能解决这个问题，然后对他造成阻力的都有什么？
是环境阻力，对手的阻力，还是自己。
内心的阻力。
最后的结果怎样？
体现了什么样的增价值？
诞生了什么样的附加值？
这就是一个。
故事的完整等待就是按照八要素去写。
当然了，你如果做成提案。
你这个八要素的梗概。
我建议你什么呢？
建议在写这个8个要素的同时。
着重体现一下。
你这个故事的创意点是什么？
什么是创业点来着？
我记得我在有一课中是这么讲。
我说你的故事啊要找一个下手的点。
或者说叫切入点锚店。
你啥玩意儿是你这个故事，你最先想到。
创意，比如说你最先想到一个。
二次动物。
还是你最先想到是是这个。
环境。
这个这个这个故事发生的环境，还是说你最先想到的是这个这个人物是挺有挺有戏的。
就是说你这个。
什么鸡巴你。
把这个故事写下去了。
就是你这个故事的创意。我当时说你可以有一个也可以有两个，对吧？也可甚至可以有三个地方都很有创意。你在这个写梗概的时候啊，把你这个创意一定要着重给他。
强调出来描述出来。
让。
看你这个提案的人知道你的创意在哪。
然后呢，这是一方面。
还有呢。
这个这个这个。
你这个故事给人的遐想。
在哪？
你也要把它写出来，为什么呢？
就是。
还是那一刻我给大家说过，我说你这个故事啊，你要一半是海水，一半是火焰呀。
很多人在听。
在听到一个故事的时候，在听到你给他讲述一个故事的时候，他会自行脑补很多东西的。
你要把这个空间留给他。
就是说他一定会脑补的那些东西，你就不要写了。
你就不要死了，你要给他一定的遐想空间。
但是就是这个在提案的梗待里面，你一定要注意这个这些东西。
一定要注意这些。
再就是这个最后的这个正价值战胜负价值体现的这个价值一定不能忘了写。这就是我们说的故事梗概把要素写上去，但是一定别忘了后面这个价值啊，因为你这个这个你这个故事的价值输出的价值对于一个一个提案来说也是非常重要的，也是你的。
这个这个金主想要知道的，你这个故事要有价值。
要有主题。
然后这就是梗概这一部分。
最后。
不一样。
我认为呀。
对于一个提案来说，你必须有。
一个样。
就是你试着写一场戏。
为啥？
因为你这些啊全部描绘的是蓝图。
蓝图啊。
就说我规划啊这个戏3个小时，我规划啊写一个什么样的英雄规划啊他要办多少大事儿。
就规划是规划的不错。
但是你如果想让人掏钱。
你必须给一个就是你能实操的证据。
所以我推荐大家再写一个样。
就是写一场具体的戏。
里面有环境描述，有动作，有有对白。
具体的。
但这场戏不是瞎选的，我一般选什么戏啊？
选一场。
主要角色在一块儿。
涉及到人物关系的文戏。
就说几个主要角色要在。
然后。
这场戏吗？
是与他们人物关系相关的一场戏。
然后呃一常吻喜舞戏，你写是只没什么写头呀，你写这种大漠孤烟，万马奔腾。虽然这场戏很漂亮，但是对吧？跟你的实力没有关系。
写一场这样的文戏。
啊，啥叫主要角色？就个人物小传这里啊，人物小传这里千千万不要把他们所有角色都写上去啊。因为我说过角色是从事儿上来的，不是你能设计出来的，你只能设计一下主角。
主要角色什么叫主要角色啊？
就是四种人，你的主角。
主角的伙伴。
主角的爱情。
主角的对手。
就这四个是主要角色啊。
就主角本人。
主角的伙伴。
主角的爱情，主角的对手。
伙伴跟爱情有时候呃只有只有一个也很正常。
星仔。
拿出。
朱丽缇。
断水流明白了吗？就主要角色就这4个四种啊。
然后呢，那样场就是写主要角色都在的。
这么一场戏，比如说。
周星驰。
去追求中立体。然后呢。
大叔在旁边帮枪，帮他一块追钟立体，然后被断水流大师兄截胡。
这么一场文戏。
能体现人物关系。
所以说这就是我们的项目提案，就比较完整。
对吧那。
这6个部分就是一个。
我认为是一个完整的项目提案，是一个漂亮的项目提案，你要写的东西。
你把这内容写齐了。
你就想不起啊拿给别人看。
才能不丢脸，不露钱。
清楚漂亮。好吧，我希望我们的同学，你如果你的项目想要拿给你的金主看的时候。
写成这个样子。
好吧。
下课。
嗯。